over the last 20 years Israel has become
a tech powerhouse they often refer to
Israel as startup nation well this is
pretty cool one of the companies that
got started here waves y'all know ways
it's how we all get around way started
in Israel there in that building right
there
let's go well this is pretty impressive
I've gone right to the top I'm talking
to guy and Fez guy you were the chief
operating officer here ways and Fez
first employee at ways right after the
founders after the fact yes of course
and then you just saw a good thing and
you hung on is that right is that you've
just been kissing a since day one heaven
we have quite an impressive operation
these people working right now are they
all mostly watching pornography how's it
work working on a specific problem and
where is this area that you're looking
at there's a whole world out there that
wants help and this guy is just working
on his route home oh yeah
I bet you tell people there's a traffic
jam when there isn't so they go a
different way and you have an easy
commute have a quick question why is the
redhead forced to sit in the back all by
himself this is the kind of prejudice
that I have been fighting since day one
hey brother yes oh no I exactly yes has
any of you ever invited this guy to
lunch invite him to lunch he's a person
too maybe you can invite Smith something
that's not gonna happen
they did a beautiful artwork of me there
they took us that the waser guide and
you turned him into me this is very nice
of you I look like a very shy sperm look
like that's a sperm that isn't confident
he's gonna fertilize anyone wow I missed
out this time maybe
is that a child I hear a child this is
terrible they have no humanity here at
ways they're putting children to work
there are laws all right can I have
everyone's attention please
this will just take a second I love ways
I think ways is an amazing app but I do
have one complaint my kids they like
this restaurant called Milo and olive
okay it's in Santa Monica we go to a
Pacific Palisades all right everything's
going fine we work our way down then you
guys have me take a right right here
okay on 14th Street terrific with you
all the way ways then you guys want me
to take a left on Montana there is no
light you can't make the left and then
my wife's like saying go now going out
I'm like I can't go now there's a car
coming
who's the person here who's gonna make
sure I don't have to take who is it she
ran away
you can't run from me I came all the way
to Tel Aviv this is Los Angeles this is
the western part of Los Angeles and
basically I'm gonna review very quickly
my kids just restaurant called Milo and
olive they liked it there because
because and that's a lean protein which
I like you get good salads the wife
likes the problem there's one time
everything's going great so I have to
take this matter
if you could solve this problem for me
that would be huge consider it solved
who do I call when I have a personal
traffic jam that I need to take care of
is it okay if that's you I can be doing
okay here's there's a big time change so
I'm gonna be calling you a lot like 3:00
in the morning for the morning anyway
okay so this could be your personal
number and you're not gonna get paid
extra for this okay this is just
something you have to do for the rest of
your life even after you leave ways and
go on to another business or start your
own company you swear to do this for the
rest of your life oh my god
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you